okay Democrats are wasting no time in
starting to mess up the 2020 primary and
potentially even the 2020 presidential
election with bogus articles stirring up
unnecessary and concocted drama and I
want to walk you through this story step
by step because it's sort of complex
although I'm confident we'll all be able
to understand it so let's go to the
beginning a story was published well we
want to go to the beginning Bernie was
screwed in the 2016 Democratic primary
that's the context in which we're
operating here a story was published
over our holiday week a holiday weekend
break I guess we would call it on NBC
News called inside Bernie world's war on
bado O'Rourke and the article is written
by Jonathan Allen and Alex cites Wald
and I've actually interviewed Alex sites
Wald before I interviewed him on the
program back in 2012 about Mitt Romney's
campaign at the time Alex was a staff
writer at salon.com this article that
was written by Jonathan Alan and Alex
cites Wald claims that there are sort of
Bernie aligned leftist supporters of
Bernie and it sort of indirectly sort of
hints that maybe there's more than just
supporters of Bernie that are involved
here who are waging some kind of war on
bado or Rourke the Democratic candidate
for Senate out of Texas who lost its
head Cruz in the November midterm
elections and it frames these Bernie
supporters very negatively and says that
minee supporters are claiming Beto's not
progressive enough that he's close to
corporate donors that he sometimes votes
for Republicans all of which are true by
the way but are also true of other
centrist Democrats as well and we'll get
to that and what this article claims to
make the case for is that the Democratic
primary is already shaping up to be
really really ugly of course before we
even know who's running yet we don't
know if Bernie's running although I
believe that that he is going to we
don't know if beta or Org is running we
don't know if Hillary Clinton is running
and that's relevant and we'll get to why
in a second and the article says that
this fight is counterproductive
now a lot of the claims being made in
the article aren't crazy in and of
themselves questioning how progressive
is beta O'Rourke is a completely
reasonable thing to do looking at
whether Democrats are going to be hurt
by an ugly primary is a completely valid
question to ask and discussion to have
but our friend and investigative
reporter David Sirota has exposed that
the article claiming that there is a
Bernie wing war on bado
O'Rourke is itself a trumped-up fake
fight David Sirota took to Twitter and
said this NBC News story accusing Bernie
of waging a war on bado was written by a
former staffer for debbie Wasserman
Schultz and a former staffer at Neera
tandon's Center for American Progress
the idea being this is establishment
Dems trying to criticize Bernie by
saying his followers are unfairly
attacking bethe O'Rourke and when you
look into it you do find that Alex cites
Wald is an assistant editor at Think
Progress org which is part of the Center
for American Progress is Action Fund
which is a main player in the Democratic
Party establishment at this point it is
indeed headed by near its hand and a
member of Hillary Clinton's advisors in
the 2016 primaries the other author of
the article Jonathan Allen worked for
debbie Wasserman Schultz the DNC chair
so this article contains some truisms it
contains write some statements that are
of course true but not particularly
meaningful just because they're true it
is a bad idea for possible Democratic
candidates to start attacking each other
now
but right that that that's true if it's
what's happening it's just not actually
what's going on it's written by
individuals tied to the establishment
Democratic Party associated with debbie
Wasserman Schultz and Hillary Clinton
who were working against Bernie Sanders
for the entire 2016 campaign so the
problem I have with this Pat number one
is that it doesn't
actually call out real infighting that's
taking place this is a fake war by
Bernie supporters on beta or Roarke it
is true that there's a growing
contingent on the internet that has
decided beta or orc is just not really a
progressive guy he's a sort of secret
establishment centrist who must be taken
down for his occasional voting with
Republicans I'm fine having the
conversation about how progressive is
beta O'Rourke and we had the
conversation and I determined he's way
better than Ted Cruz and we should
obviously vote for him in Texas but the
idea of a Bernie supporter war on bado
written by these particular people
stinks of astroturf to me me too I think
when the 2020 presidential race does
come around there's going to be a wide
pool of democratic candidates and you're
gonna have some establishment types in
there maybe like beta O'Rourke and even
have some progressives in there maybe
like Bernie Sanders and they'll probably
be some infighting at that point and
that could be healthy there's an
argument to be made that's that's
actually good for the party but it has
to happen naturally it has to be organic
I mean you can't you can't just stage
something like this no question about it
look during the Republican primary which
started with 17 candidates there was
significant infighting and ultimately
the party rallied around the whacky
inexperienced totally clueless person
that won the nomination which was Donald
Trump and the discussions that were
taking place within the Republican
primary for often based on the physical
appearance of people but and and
nicknaming them but that's okay I mean
it's still just an example of the fact
that that internal debate can happen
when it's actually taking place that's
fine to report on it this is not
actually happening there is no big
Bernie attack or war on bado there are
just reasonable people who may have
voted for Hillary Clinton or Bernie or
whoever who are evaluating possible
candidates and sometimes giving their
opinion and the truth is of course
rarely as black and white as either this
is fake astroturf drama or this is real
Beto's not the perfect candidate he lost
in 2018 there are many options for 2024
Democrats who could be better than beta
O'Rourke but beta or Roarke is not the
problem Bernie Sanders supporters are
not the problem and Democrats need to
start working now to prevent the 2020
primary from being destroyed possibly in
even worse ways than the 2016 primary
was destroyed send me your thoughts if
you have questions about this or
anything else I've been taking questions
on the David Pakman show Instagram page
for the last 24 hours I will be taking
them for a few more hours follow the
show on instagram at david pakman show
and while you're there follow me at
David Pakman today's program was made
possible in part by Blink accom slash
Pakman i love bling cast it's the really
perfect app for anybody who likes
politics and learning and if you're
watching or listening to the david
pakman show I'm sure you'll love
politics and learning and what blinka
says is take the best and most popular
non-fiction books they condense them
into 15-minute audiobooks that you can
listen to in one sitting and you can
learn about politics philosophy
psychology economics often we don't have
the time to actually read as many books
as we would like I know that I'm at my
limit for how much I can read and this
way you can absorb the most important
valuable information from books in just
15 minutes maybe on your way to work
maybe on your way to the gym maybe
cooking vegan recipes at home whatever
is your thing and our audience can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you like it and I think you will you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for just about 5 bucks a
month you can go to be li NK is t.com
slash PA k ma n to sign up